good morning it is 9 00 a.m
on wednesday march 24th
uh welcome to ways and means we are
going to recess the meeting until
10 30 today
10 30 a.m the meeting will be recessed
jen why don't you go ahead and put the
uh
little display up
will do and connie you you just heard
that we're recessed until 10 30.
i did not but now i did oh
jump back see you then
very good thanks thanks
situations invented sad relationships
so
morning everyone good morning ellen
good morning
who are the substitutions today jenny do
you know that or norm
who's lisa poston for any idea um
yeah for mary griffin
it's uh representative lisa post
okay thank you
mr chairman i hope your meeting went
well
guess what it was cancelled
what can i say
you bring everybody back together
and plan for another day yep
that means you have to buy lunch now
jenny are there any substitutions on the
from
your caucus i think there's going to be
someone in for tom lockman
but i don't think they had anybody yet
yesterday
okay you know in the morning that i know
well
tell your husband tell your husband to
stand by just in case
no he's blowing the leaves out of my
gardens i'm going to leave him alone
i have a question on this representative
major
yes why are there
years 2018 and 19.
that was corrected oh okay
mistake all right
all right you're the first one to catch
that
well i was waiting for someone to say
something yesterday but we didn't really
look at it so
all right
susan do you have any uh substitutions
for
laughter
sorry we were supposed to have connie
lane
i don't know if she's in the attendees
she was here early she was here at nine
o'clock and uh
she was alerted that we'll reconvene at
10 30 so i think she'll be here okay
i did tell her that that it was 10 30
but i guess that didn't get through very
well
she's not here yetish not that i can see
and while um
we're waiting next week
because we are different than most
committees
we're not sure
what we might be facing with
so i have a placeholder for
tuesday afternoon at one o'clock
and then wednesday and thursday at nine
o'clock
if we are successful today we'll have
three bills
left and our committee needs three
senate bills and uh
we plan on working on those next week
plus we may have to react
relative to revenues
and i don't know if there are any uh
senate bills for ways and means coming
from tomorrow's session in the senate
but
there may be some more i'm sure they're
holding a lot of stuff to put in the
budget
so we'd have to look at them
[Music]
if they hold them
big one is the ppp senate bill 3
that theoretically is coming our way
yeah that's another big one that one's
going to take a
day by itself
and i'll get into the fun part of that
bonnie is here now susan
yes i saw hi connie
i thought as i was signing on i heard
that recording it started
it is it's on it has been going since
nine o'clock
so if anybody wants to listen in they'll
listen
to uh nothing for an hour and a half
now you should hear the things we were
saying about you guys
if if this mode cut this part out
we we really need to figure out a way to
i was talking to jen about it yesterday
to bookmark the different hearings
because if you go and try to re hear
something it's hit and miss you have to
fast forward and figure out what bill
you're on
and yeah because i miss stuff doing this
job and so i
i try and listen to pieces again it's a
pain in the butt
i don't i don't know what the solution
would be to that
an index afterwards maybe with you know
the time frames
i'm hoping we can go back to normal uh
soon
well i think they bookmark the sessions
don't they you can usually
when you listen back on a session i
think they're bookmarked
i don't know i'm not sure yeah
when i when i when i look back on
session i usually scroll and scroll and
scroll
until we get to the right place
when it's in the chamber you can see the
bill number up on the
you know the example yeah
just for new members uh we were one of
the few committees historically that
had recorded our our wage and means
meetings
not every committee had a recording um
but we we have and i think i think
finance is probably recorded as well
i think it's videoed but um
but we were one of the few so so
it's a major step that everybody's is
now recording
which is not a bad thing and i agree
that should be
benchmarked that would be great
to see we get paid extra for that
bob you just have to watch your p's and
q's because whatever you say is for
posterity
you get you get royalties and all the
the monetization of the ad revenue from
you oh that's good to know you'll find
yourself on youtube right
okay recording in in uh
we were the first committee outside of
fine and finance had a stenographer not
a recording
i guess they're recording too
okay it is now 10 31 we
get started um and we are recording
janine
right okay
so i'll have to read the script
as chair of the house boys and means
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the program 19 pandemic
in accordance with hospitals 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is an executive session and bill's
assigned to the news and means committee
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporariously to this
meeting however in accordance with
emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available on the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
you'll notice for this meeting complies
with health rules irsa
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271 3600 or email hcs
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is under unable
to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting
assisting us christopher shea and brad
greenland in gen 4
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room review
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
representative bernstein you want to
call the role
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you and good morning to everyone it is
march 24th 2021 it's 10 30 a.m
let's begin roll call with
representative pat abrami
i'm here in my home in stratham uh and
i'm alone
and i'd like to give a warm ways and
means welcome to representative lisa
post
substituting for mary griffin
thank you i am in my home i do have
two people in here i'm up in my office i
have a headset in the microphone
thank you i'm glad to be here today
thank you representative jordan owerry
i'm here in hudson my wife is in the
house someplace
representative russ over here in hudson
with the six cats representative fred
ducette
good morning my home office in salem
alone
your clerk is alan bursty and i'm in my
home office in nottingham new hampshire
representative robert elliott i'm here
in salem new hampshire and my wife
is in the living room good morning
representative john ginidian
hi good morning i'm in my home office in
salem and my
wife is in the house representative
herschel nunes
good morning i'm home alone in pelham
thank you
representative tim baxter thank you mr
clerk i'm home alone
representative walter spillsberry good
morning
home alone in charlestown
paul tudor good morning home alone in
northwood
representative susan alby good morning
home alone in lebanon
representative richard ames here home
alone
in my home office in jeffrey
representative thomas southworth
home here alone in dover representative
dennis malloy
here in greenland um hello
representative thomas schamberg good
morning mr clerk i'm home
in my uh office and my wife's in her
office and willmott
good morning representative edith tucker
you muted representative tucker excuse
me
i'm home alone in randolph
good morning representative gomarlo i'm
home in swansea and my husband is around
substituting for tom lofman is
representative connie lane welcome to
ways and means
representative lane thank you i'm home
alone in my home office in concord
representative amanda gorg
good morning i am here and alone
representative mary hacken phillips
morning i'm coming to you from my office
alone in concord
representative james murphy good morning
i'm alone in my home office in hanover
and the chairman of ways and means
representative norman major
good morning i'm in my home office and
my wife is in the house
mr mr chair apparently the ticket to
a seat it weighs in means is tough to
get all 24 of us are here
there are no vacancies that's great
today all we're going to deal with is
executive sessions on
five house bills and three senate bills
first house bill is house bill
creating animals record database
do i hear a motion to get the discussion
style
representative tutor moves that uh hp
532 be retained
representative tutor moves hb 532 be
retained
seconded by i'll second it mr
chairman representative nunez
seconded by representative nunez
discussion
uh representative tutu going to say
anything
yes mr chair we felt that the removal of
the
fees for the certificates was a mistake
and the bill should be self-funding
should be retained so we can work on
that funding source
representative thank you
mr chair this is something of a
uh shock because they've been trying to
get this through for several years
and they really uh
strongly feel they need it as does
finance
on division one on
but on and it is now too late
since this was just decided on on the
republican
side on two to
restore the fees that we worked on
extensively
last term and which we have the language
for
um but the reason the fees are not there
is that on the
legislature has been told by your
leadership that
no fees should ever get passed in this
term so there is
enough money in those dedicated funds
that they are rating
that they will not need it restored
because it was built up during a period
when
agriculture was not doing its job
in those areas and
it appears also that there may be too
much money
in the animal products fund
coming into the animal products fund
since it's being used as a slush fund
for the
entire department
that's something that really needs to be
looked at later doesn't really work
being
looked at here and
it will get looked at later if in no
other way
when on the dedicated fund committee
gets it back on rotation
um but
i really feel that they
they are really very little computerized
in the department of agriculture
this is there is a major step
for them in on getting their paperwork
under control which is essentially on
paper
everywhere and they have very few staff
they are generally one of the least
funded departments
in terms of overall funds
in the state government and
have been putting things together as far
as i'm concerned with chewing gum
since before i arrived in the
legislature
so on getting this one started
which is going to require a year of
going out to bid and getting a
software system developed
i think is getting really urgent
and i would appeal that
we just pass this on to the senate and
put a bookmark in our minds that
that something is going to have to be
done to look at
at um the animal products
funding and at
at the whole fee structure probably if
the department thank you
well thank you for your testimony
representative there's
one thing though you had said that
our leadership told us
there would be no fees
i in my party i have not heard that from
my leadership
oh okay
um well all all of the committees seem
to be thinking that
so that's the 700
representative
representative schamberg here i do
believe that
representative almi was referring to the
january 6
speech made by the present speaker at
the time that he was running for office
thank you about the fees
thank you for your comment
uh any further comment on senate bill
i mean house bill 532.
saying no mr chairman could i ask
if we retain this bill or are we going
to ask
the division one of finance to remove
the money that they put in the budget to
help with this effort
that's a good question
then no further hands raised
we need to go to the vote on retain
house bill
532 so to collect recall
role on retaining house bill 532 if
you're in favor you'll vote yes
do not vote no thank you mr chair we'll
begin the roll call vote the motion
is retained representative abrami
yes representative post
i apologize i had trouble on muting yes
representative hollery yes
representative ober
yes giusette yes
first team votes yes tell me yes
junior yes
representative nunes nunez votes yes
baxter yes spillsbury
yes representative tudor yes
omni no
ames no
southworth no
representative malloy no
representative thomas schamberg
representative schamberg votes no
representative tucker no
representative gomarlo no
representative connie lane no
representative gorg yes
representative hacken phillips
no representative murphy
no chairman major
yes mr chair the
vote to retain hp 532
is 14 years 10 mays the motion carries
the vote 14 to 10 the motion retained
varies
next is house bill 610-fn
an act requiring certain licensing and
reporting functions to be conducted
through the nationwide multi-state
licensing system and registry
and relative to background investigation
of trust officers to certain
filing fees assessments and interest
rates
into the transmission of consumer
complaints by the banking department
i move uh ought to pass uh
on a house bill uh 610.
representative bromley moves lots of
pass on health bill 610
second and by i'll second it
represent elmy
roxanna yes um
this is a large housekeeping bill uh
that was requested by the banking
committee
uh it passed commerce nothing 19 to
nothing it was on consent calendar
the our only concern in the bill is on
page six
line 36 it's the fee
for new state bank and credit union
charters
uh the fee is going up from ten thousand
to fifteen thousand
and we heard testimony that um
uh for these type of uh charter
the charter work that they do that uh
the average is closer to fifteen
thousand and they decided that it's best
that
we increase this fee to fifteen thousand
and if if if it goes beyond that if the
cost of
of of uh chartering these the bank or
credit unions
goes beyond that uh there's a provision
for
additional fees to be added on so
that's the only thing we're dealing with
and i support that that move
thank you further comments on house bill
representative thank you just to make
sure that people don't think
we overlooked it on
the fee on
on there's a fee at the bottom of page
six
which increases the the uh
costs for on setting up a new
bank or credit union charter by
50 and the
on and then on page seven is where the
the uh allowance for
adding on and giving the notification
to the places that they're going to add
on so they can back out if they want to
on if the the cost of
processing the application goes too high
any further discussion of questions on
house bill 610
saying none that i'm going to ask the
clerk
to call the vote on house bill 610
the motion is ought to pass if you're in
favor you're voting yes
you're not you won't
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote with representative abrami
yes representative post
representative cs
representative owery
i'm sorry yes there you are i see you
representative ober yes
representative doucette yes
the clerk votes yes representative
elliott
yes representative gennadian
yes
representative nunes representative
representative baxter yes representative
spillsbury
yes ames yes
southward yes
yes representative thomas schamberg
representative schamberg votes yes
tucker
yes go marlo
yes lane
yes gorg
yes nice office you got there
representative
hacken phillips yes
murphy yes german major
yes mr chair of the vote is 24
yays zero nays
so then 24 to zero the motion about to
pass
without objection go on consent
without objection so go on consent
next is house bill 614-fn
enact exempting the state and political
subdivisions on the payment of the cost
of compliance
with the renewable portfolio standards
representative baxter
thank you mr chair i'd like to make a
motion
to table hb614
no it can't be tabled excuse me
sorry mr chair i apologize to retain
okay second set
second it it's pat representative
baxter made the motion to retain
seconded by
representative romney
representative baxter i want to speak to
you in motion
thank you mr chair uh this is a pretty
simple
uh straightforward motion uh to retain
this bill the prime sponsor of the bill
has asked us to retain it and it's just
not ready at this point in time to go
forward the bill needs more work
and so i think this can be a pretty
straightforward among all members of the
committee to retain
this piece of legislation thank you mr
chair
also the prime sponsor
notified us that the wrong
amendment is put into the bill
it isn't the amendment that was passed
by the science and technology
and by retaining it we can work out
something and
i'm sure that we couldn't adopt that
amendment unless we had
a public hearing on that amendment
it might not be possible for us we might
be
if in our work sessions
i'll have to check with the speaker to
see if um
science and technology can join us
and then we'll figure something out
any further discussion representative
tucker
representative baxter does your emotion
leave everything in place
working for the various subdivisions and
so forth that have become
very involved in this kind of work
everything remains the same while we
study
thank you representative tucker i
believe so and as
the as the chair said the purpose of
this motion
is to allow them to continue to work on
it if the prime sponsor and other
uh people are working on the legislation
um would like to
would like to do so and mr chair you can
correct me if i'm wrong on that
uh retaining is acceptable
to uh representative loss who's the
prime sponsor
and also chairman of the science
technology
committee i guess my my concern if i
could follow up mr chairman
is that it turns out that
really a lot of people are dependent
upon the
work that is done under current
legislation
and i want to make sure everything stays
in place
for those projects and efforts that are
going forward
i would imagine that if they're working
under current
law they will be because
there's nothing changed because we
haven't passed
this legislation good thank you that's
my greatest concern here
thank you any further discussion
i saw your hand go up and uh
somehow sometimes when i
pressed on mute it takes the hand down
at the same time and sometimes it
doesn't i do not understand it
on the uh there is a major
complicating factor which is in hb2
and in the budget which is the
governor's uh
something like 70-page proposal to
create a department of energy and stick
the puc
and the sec and a whole bunch of other
things
including the planning section of the
governors
into a department of energy
uh we have no idea how that is going to
pass
uh in in the end what the senate might
do with it what
what they're doing right now in uh the
finance committee
on but that is certain to affect
both this bill and 624
in some at least some way in fact it
already has because he
seems to have been preparing things um
so on i i hope that we will
be able to keep in contact on
both with with whoever
ends up being in charge of the
department of energy
and uh if she is still there with the
puc
chair on as as we work on this
and that we do not try to start to work
on this until after the budget is passed
thank you representative
yes as we've discussed you know there's
the the error in the amendment
uh which poses a complication for us uh
so
i think the reasonable thing to do is to
retain uh as we work through
how we can engage uh the science and
tech
through discussions with the speaker and
and the clerk
uh what what's the best way to handle
this
and the only other comment i have is is
uh
representative tucker uh that yes i mean
uh the earliest let's say we work on it
over the late summer
and and fall uh the earliest any amended
bill would come out would be
january so everything remains in place
until then then it has to go to the
senate so
so things will be in place for for quite
a while with this rent retention
thank you representative ames
thank you i just wanted to uh first say
that i
i definitely support the motion to
retain
um and thank representative baxter for
putting it forward
and um reasons for retention
certainly include the uh the amendment
that was
misplaced or mishandled but they go way
beyond that there are serious issues
that
have surfaced as uh as we've looked at
this bill we've received
lots of information some of it on the
policy some of it
that relates uh more closely to
our our expertise but uh
but i look forward to working um
across the board on that on all of those
issues probably with
the science technology and energy
committee because of the
uh the the amendment problem that we're
facing so uh i just wanted to make
clear that this is a large
challenge that reaches across many
dimensions and i look forward to working
on it
thank you representatives any further
questions or comments on house bill 614
saying none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
and the vote is to retain if you're in
favor
you'll say yes do not no
representative bernstein thank you mr
chair let's begin our roll call vote on
hb 614 with the motion of retain
representative abrami yes
representative post representative
post votes yes representative hollery
yes ober yes ducette
yes first gene votes yes elliot
yes tunisian
yes
sorry nunes yes
baxter yes spillsbury
yes tudor yes
army yes ames
yes southworth
yes representative thomas schamberg
representative schamberg votes yes mr
cork
thank you sir representative tucker yes
go marlo yes lane
yes gorg yes
atkin phillips yes murphy
yes german major yes
mr chair the motion carries by a vote of
24-0
the vote been 24-0 motion to retain
passes
period
it will be reported out has been
retained with the other retained
bills at the next session
the next is house bill 615-fn
an act reducing the penalty for certain
first offense
drug possession charges uh
representative bernstein
thank you mr chair i would like to move
uh ought to pass
on hb 615. representative bernstein
knows octopass
and seconded my
second representation
representative bernstein i want to speak
to your motion sure
thank you mr chair uh hb 615 passed the
house
hit the ways and means committee heard
this as a second committee bill
and we were specifically looking at the
reduction
in the amount of fines um
which in the spirit of the bill is is a
rather minor part of it
uh so we're going to acquiesce with the
policy committee
and recommend that this bill be enacted
with an ought to pass motion
uh representative yes thank you mr chair
uh as i said yesterday i i wanted to see
this bill retained
and that was my heart talking i i i
still have a feeling that where
some of these fee fines are for
uh dealers as well as fentanyl
are going down and i i just have a
problem with that
but with that said and then uh from the
discussion yesterday with the full
committee and then with the discussion
with the um with the republican caucus
yesterday afternoon
uh i i've changed my mind and and
will go along with the ought to pass
motion
and there's two reasons when i look at
the bill
really the essence of the bill the
policy of the bill
really is the fines in this and and the
uh
and the sentences and uh as we talked
about yesterday
some of us said on both sides uh both
parties said
we're not sure why we got this bill
anyway
so that's one one thing and then the
second thing is uh
you know i've been the police chiefs
reached out to me
uh and they they want to continue
arguing this and i think it was
representative amy
that said and i i agree with her that
there's a second bite at the apple for
them
in the senate uh committee that it will
go to
and and that's probably the place that
it should be uh just further discussed
so with that i will be supporting the
ought to
pass motion
today any further discussion on
hospital 615
saying then i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the
vote about to pass on house bill
615 if you're in favor say yes oppose
no representative bernstein thank you mr
chair let's begin the roll call vote
with representative abrami
yes host yes
ori
yes over
representative ober yes uh
he's gotta show him yes god
there you go
thank you representative over
representative ducette
yes the clerk votes yes
representative elliott yes
gennady yes nunes
yes baxter yes spillsbury
yes tudor yes
army yes ames
yes southworth
yes malloy yes
representative thomas schamberg
representative schamberg votes yes mr
cork
thank you sir representative tucker yes
go marlo
yes thank you representative lane
yes gorg
yes hacking phillips stuff
murphy yes chairman major
yes mr chair of the vote is 24
in favor zero opposed and now
it's consent mr chairman
[Laughter]
you jump the gun the vote being 24-0
the motion of what to pass passes and
without objection
we'll go on consent
thank you i'd just like to request that
the blurb say something about the
committee
on realizing that the
fines involved are are an
intimate part of the policy of the
policy committee
truly noted i'll make sure that's
included in my blurb representative
so there's no objection to consent
it will go on the consent calendar
next is house bill 624-fn
an act decreasing the fee to file a
petition for declaratory ruling
with a site evaluation committee
representative zhakishin thank you
mr chairman i make a motion to retain
house bill 624.
your motion okay um yes
this primarily deals with line two the
petition for declaratory
ruling um and
i think it needs a little more study as
to whether
reducing those fees from ten thousand
five hundred for the full committee
hearing and three thousand
for a three-member panel reducing that
to just
one fee of 250 dollars i think there's
some concern that it could open the
floodgates
and um and the cost of these
rulings um could which are which are
based on testimony we're in the eight to
ten thousand dollar range
um i think we need to look at those
numbers and possibly
come up with new numbers there
thank you
[Music]
representative thank you i'd just like
to
ask people to to keep and read
on the uh email that was sent to all of
us by diane martin the head of the pfc
and the head of the sec
because they weren't she wasn't given
enough money to replace the one who quit
uh about the funding of the sec
on there is in it a decision
from a ruling from
the ag's office about what the funding
is supposed to be
and there is also the petition to
the fiscal committee as well as
on what kind of funding
they've actually been getting they they
are really
on starvation wages and if they are
asked to do anything
it may be very difficult to do it so
um that i think needs to
come in with our discussions but also
the whole department of energy
piece has got to come into the
discussions thank you
thank you representative further
questions and discussions
soon then i'll ask the clerk to call the
vote
on retain if you're in favor you say yes
suppose no uh representative berenson
thank you mr chair we will begin the
roll call vote with representative obama
yes representative post
representative post votes yes
representative owery
yes ober yes
you said yes
clerk berstein votes yes elliot yes
canadian yes nunes
yes baxter yes
spillsbury yes
tudor yes
army yes
ames yes southward
yes malui yes
representative thomas schamberg
representative schamberg voces
tucker yes go marlo
yes name yes
gorg yes hacking phillips
yes murphy yes
chairman major yes mr chair of the vote
is 24 yes
zero no
the vote to retain 24 yes
and 0-000 it passes
now we'll go to the senate bills
did you want to say that i would be
going on the consent calendar
that's a retain bill i'm sorry my
mistake
only makes two of us
i said that makes two of us mr chairman
it's easy easy enough
senate bills 23.
an act changing the requirement that a
member of the sponsoring charitable
organization
be present during the certain games of
chance
representative tudor representative
tudor
makes a motion to our octopass for sb 23
second second by representative elliott
representative tudor you want to stick
to the emotion
thank you mr chair yes this bill makes
changes to the requirements
charitable organizations must be present
during the gaming gaming operation
this bill eliminates that requirement in
the past
the charitable organizations have had a
larger role in the day-to-day gaming
activities
today they simply show up sign the form
and leave
uh each day during during the event so
this bill just
just eliminates the requirement for them
to do that
anybody else wants to make a statement
or a comment uh preston elliott
thank you mr chairman i just want to say
that
salem years ago the uh
the whole club had to be at the uh
windows and then the rule was changed to
just the president or the
treasurer would be there and
we all thought that really we were
not really needed as long as we get the
dates
and so that's the present bill but after
all this time
uh the state has decided to let
the outsiders uh do all the work and we
get all the money
which we're grateful for thank you mr
chairman
thank you representative uh
any further questions or comments
saying none i'll ask the court to call
the role
on ought to pass during favors say yes
if not say no and representative
bernstein
thank you mr chair this is a vote on sb
we'll begin the roll call vote with
representative obama yes
representative post yes
overy yes
ober yes
ducette yes first dean votes yes
elliot yes
genigen yes
nunes yes baxter
yes spillsberry yes
tudor yes army
yes ames
yes southworth
yes malloy
yes representative thomas
schamberg representative schamberg votes
yes mr cork
thank you sir tucker yes
go marlow representative jenny gomarlo
votes yes
thank you ma'am representative lane
yes gorg
yes hacking phillips
yes murphy
yes chairman major
yes is to share the motion to ought to
pass carries 24 to nothing the vote
being 24 or nothing on ought to pass
it passes and without consent they would
go on consent
without opposition everyone consent
uh anybody opposed to going on the
consent calendar
all right go on the consent calendar
next one is senate bill 25 relative to
charity gaming licenses representative
thank you mr chairman i'd like to make a
motion of otp on
senate bill 25.
a second representation
represent a safety emotion
thank you mr chairman uh as is stated on
the front page of the bill it's this is
just a changing of the term
about licensing uh just letting them uh
do some housekeeping internal inside the
department so
otp on this is great
any further discussion or questions
comments
any further comments or questions on
senate bills 25. mr chairman
i hope the blurb would mention that this
is reverting to
a prior system that worked a lot better
for the
department and the charities
we can certainly put that in there
representative alame thank you very much
and thank you mr representative
all right no further questions or
comments
i have to click call the role on
a vote to pass on senate bill 25
if you're in favor vote yes otherwise
you vote no
representative bernstein thank you mr
chair representative obrami
yes host yes
worry yes over
yes to set yes
bursting votes yes elliot yes
canadian yes nunes
yes baxter yes
spillsbury yes tudor
yes army
yes
the cameras caught that representative
obama
uh representative ames
yes southward
yes malloy yes representative thomas
schamberg
representative schamberg voces tucker
yes representative jenny gomarlo
one more time yes
thank you thank you thank you
representative lane
yes gorg yes
hacking phillips yes murphy
yes the chairman major yes
mr chair the vote is 24 in favor
zero opposed the motion for ought to
pass carries
with a vote of 24-0 the motion about the
past passes
and without objection one consent
any objection no objection so it
own the content calendar
we're really plopping these off this is
the last one
senate bill 48 and act
relative to the formula used to
determine current use
tax rates representative spillsbury
thank you mr chairman
i'd like to move that the committee
approved otp on senate bill 48
representative spellsdory makes the
motion about to pass on senate bill 48
and seconded by representative schamberg
would second that mr chairman
president
representative spellsbury you want to
speak to your motion
yes thank you and thank you
representative chamber
this is a basic good government bill
it's the sort of bill that reminds us
there
are things in the law that surprise us
senator guyda the primary sponsor
indicated this is the only tax rate
whose formulation is currently allowed
to be kept confidential
so in the spirit of full transparency
i think we can all agree the formula
should be
a matter of public record and open to
review uh senator gaida also
assured us that even though the formula
will now be public the underlying raw
data
can still be protected and kept
confidential so it's a simple bill
and a non-controversial bill no
objections were registered at the
hearing
any questions or comments on senate bill
seeing none i'm gonna
have to click call the vote on senate
bill 48
of ought to pass and if you're in favor
you say yes
if you're not saying no representative
bernstein
thank you mr chair we'll begin the roll
call vote with representative abrami
yes post yes
or worry yes ober
yes you set yes
first dean votes yes elliot yes
yes nunes
yes baxter
yes spillsbury
yes tudor
yes army
yes yes
southward yes malloy
yes representative thomas schamberg
representative schamberg votes yes mr
corp thank you sir
representative tucker yes representative
jenny gomarlo
yes lane
yes
yes chairman major yes
mr chair of the vote is 24 to nothing in
favor of the vote about to pass
is 24 to nothing therefore it passes
without objection you go on the consent
calendar
we have an objection so it will appear
on the consent calendar
mr chair i just want to say to alan i
think we may have set a record on that
one in terms of uh
vote speed
i'd like to thank all the little people
who made this class
wrong party for doing that alan wrong
party
we're scheduled to meet tomorrow but we
finished our work today so
we will not be meeting tomorrow next
week
since we are different than most
committees
we have to be prepared and the only way
we can meet
is to make sure it appears in the
calendar
so i put placeholders in next week for
tuesday wednesday and thursday
tuesday will be one o'clock wednesday
and thursday will be nine o'clock
be prepared to go to work if required
if we can get somebody from ncsl or
some other expertise to talk to us
relative to the stimulus package
and we need to understand what's in the
stimulus package that's going to affect
our revenues
we need to do that right away
so
just hang loose and let's
enjoy tomorrow and we'll see how next
week works out
but we should at least look at the uh
the three remaining bills that we have
from the senate
that we retain that hasn't been voted on
yet
mr chair would that more than likely be
tuesday afternoon
it'll be tuesday afternoon we'll try to
get work done tuesday afternoon
if possible then by then i should know
whether or not
we have some expertise coming in
this can just ask okay sorry
may i ask is in the calendar is it
posted that way that we'll be working on
those three bills
in the calendar it will say the work
session
on on senate bills okay
and and revenues
all right thank you
and we may get some uh senate bills
uh depends on what they pass
and send over they make class bills and
table
too but we don't know that yet
and if they do send them over then since
it's in the calendar we can start
working on
any questions
what things went wrong
mr chairman if it is possible
before tuesday to that
that you know that we're going to use
part of wednesday or thursday
could you send it to us because normally
our committee would not be doing much
next
week and i at least scheduled
some appointments that i've been putting
off for a long time
like medical thanks
i will do that i may be
hung up next week too because
i've got a medical operation on friday
and
see how that works out
all right uh norm uh it's pat again
the reason i asked that question was uh
uh
when i'll i'll alert a lottery to make
sure there's somebody from lottery
at that hearing at that work session uh
because if it's not posted that way they
they may not know but i'll just make
sure they're aware that they were going
to be talking about their
three lucky seven bills right
and those are bills that are still in
our possession we haven't voted on that
right right but i'll let charlie know
okay anything else
all right enjoy the rest of the day
and thank you thank you mr chairman